[Music]
how popular is the tax cut and Jobs Act
Donald Trump's 2017 signature law and
has it given the president of boost in
the polls
very few pollsters ask people regularly
about the law The Economist you go poll
is an exception they've asked about it
virtually every week since passage and
the ratings are stable where the pinyon
usually tilting slightly against the law
and their latest online polled 34%
supported it and 39% were opposed with
nearly three and ten having no opinion
in a March Fox News poll 42% of
registered voters approved of the way
President Trump is handling taxes while
48 percent disapproved the Gallup poll
from February 2019 also produced a
negative verdict on Trump and taxes
public perceptions of the economy have
been very good lately and President
Trump
usually gets positive marks from the
majority of the public on handling it
but Rosie views about the economy are
not changing in a positive way people's
perceptions of the tax law nor have they
boosted views of the President on
handling taxes what do you think about
President Trump's tax cut and Jobs Act
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI